white gay privilege so there's an
article that came out today
uh for lgbtq plus people of color racism
also impacts how they are perceived it
is a sad reality that being part of a
marginalized societal group exposes you
to hate discrimination and an unequal
treatment it's a fact well known by
people in the lgbt
clue
plus community who experience this kind
of hostility based on their gender and
or sexuality however
for people whose identities intersect
multiple marginalized groups there are
more things to consider for people of
color racism also impacts how they are
perceived and treated by wider society
so people from the lgbtq plus community
who do not have to worry about racism as
well possess white gay privilege i think
i knew white gay privilege was a thing
before we had a name for it lady phil
one of the founders of uk black pride
tells metro code at uk and this is just
the beginning of intersectionality
eating its own i think the fact that as
soon as you have intersecting uh
hierarchies of grievance and privilege
it's no longer enough to just be gay you
know douglas murray was sat in that very
seat where you're sat and he said that
because he's gay and conservative he's
basically straight now he's an honorary
straight
and uh
this i mean if no one can see that this
is the beginning of a circular firing
squad where the purity spiral just
continues to shave off people on the
outside that are no longer sufficiently
oppressed so hang on oh you're white and
gay
i'm afraid that that kind of means
you're not that gay anymore friend
you don't get to have the same
oppression olympics that we do yeah no i
i i've heard a few gay men white gay men
before speak of things in this direction
that didn't have a term yet
but
and to the point of of like the the
again it's like the world of
the world of bloggers blogging at other
bloggers about what they should blog
about and there and and it's it's like a
roberto snake eating it's it's own tail
kind of thing where i'm so disconnected
from that world it's not the world of
like how to say
like
i i feel we've
we've got so much um
it's it's interesting like
existential
fear
is so high
in terms of like it's so hard to make
money or to get to a level we're
comparing ourselves to people who are
further and further and further away
from where we are now right we've got
all of this chatter this noise that
we're that we've got to deal with and
yet we're so
not everybody but we're so safe
there's i think of i got to go on safari
in africa for example and uh with my
friend who who like guided us
literally on the ground on foot
lions and tigers and bears oh my like
you're on the ground there's a riot we
were tracking a rhino for a long time
and then we got to this place where it
was like oh [ __ ] it's right on the other
side of that bush we could hear it
breathing and it smelled us and it could
tell something was up and you can hear
it getting a little like irritated like
what's going on and when a rhino
just starts running and it could easily
just run in this direction and just you
know he literally just has a horn they
call a group of rhinos a crash of rhinos
because they can run like 60 miles an
hour and see eight feet in front of them
right they're like a group the group of
rhinos is called a crash of rhinos i
love the names of like a flamboyance of
flamingos and you know
but
in that space
first of all your nervous system goes oh
i remember this [ __ ] because we're
talking
millions and millions of years that's
what we're shaped by
oh i remember this that was clarifying
it felt grounding in a strange way
um
teeth and horns and claws nature red and
tooth and claw
were so far from that not saying that
like
louis ck has this amazing bit it's like
we should let one lion loose in new york
just one
just one
so any time you're walking anywhere it's
like
a little bit more just donating it's a
bit more exciting just like yeah i made
it this time but the
the distance that we have from
from
what it takes to make
civilization work
is i think uh one
reason why we're able to circle jerk as
intensely as we can around who
who is living in injustice which type of
gay person is the one that's got the
most oppression yeah well i mean
the problem that you have is that only
in a world that's this convenient would
you be able to lap with
so many different games that you're
playing
i heard this quote the other day which
is so perfect and it said the
demand for racism outstrips the supply
[Laughter]
at the moment that's a fascinating idea
yeah and what you think about is that
the ibrahmax candies of the world and
the anti-racism trainers of the world
and the people who take the social
status from it not even the people that
make money you know just the people that
are able to tweet about it
the people who rely on racism to give
them their sense of self and position
and power in the world
need racism to continue so what do they
do they continue to expand the
definition of racism to encompass more
and more and more things i just re i
just spent um some good time with a
native american teacher he's a comanche
and
he's a descendant of quanah parker who
is the the
last chief of of the comanches and
and i
like
in experiences with him
like i get to learn so much about like a
land literally taken from people
and
and i connect i i just i love learning
more about that even though is actually
really
visceral like to learn about like the
the fact that we're really on like we
really
are privy or or
accomplice in some way to this
to like these people live with this
and they keep they're they're still here
they keep living and quantum was
actually a really interesting
bridge between those worlds
um between his world and and the world
that that he like was coaching is people
like hey man this is coming we have to
do something about this and he's he's
like you can take our land but you can't
take our medicine you can't take our way
of life
uh
i
i definitely connect to that story i
connect to the i mean i had
this coffee book when i was young of
martin luther king and i remember in
high school just learning about the
civil rights and just going like
like just
what the hell
this is
and it just defined me the this struggle
this like the the that that people
and that people hey that people were
treated that way and then and then it
just kept getting more intense the
layers of it just the realization of how
pervasive
this activity of of owning people
putting them to work the differing
levels of of who gets treated in what
way
uh different classifications of people
different i still feel very strongly
that we live in like a caste system
there are different sort of casts
just it just feels like i'm in the stage
that i'm in we all have i think i
believe in the opportunities for upward
mobility
and i believe in and this might sound
like a shitty [ __ ] bearded white
thing to say but this there's a kind of
a value in accepting where i am
as like this is my this is my level this
is where i'm at in life because then
because then i can like i can feed my
family i can i can do these things i can
feel the richness of it and not
continually strive i mean that's that's
yeah that's an interesting way to look
at it that's an inner citadel that you
can retreat to as well right or a cop
i've got to come to terms with it right
but the reason that it's so satisfying
and so reassuring and comforting to get
to is that it stops the drive it stops
at least a little bit of the drive for
more yeah i'm looking for excuses to
feel satisfied yeah precisely but again
the ancient greek word for work used to
be not at leisure yeah like
it shouldn't be the case that you feel
like your primary source of value to the
world as a father of like
lots of children and a husband and a
creator and all of this stuff the
primary source of value to the world is
whether or not you can double your
income over the next five years yeah
that's not supposed to be the way that
we're supposed to value each other
but in a world which is bereft of
community and connection and
[Music]
sense of
um belonging to the
wider mythos of the the
nation that you're in
what have you got yeah well i've got my
bank account i've got my social media
followers and i've got my watch time on
youtube an endless possibility yeah and
i've got my ability to accuse other
people in my group of not being as
oppressed as me yeah and it's just
different all of that is just like i
lived in portland for 15 years and i was
really uh
sort of kind of by default in
in a world somewhat like that
and i've since just gotten so far away
from it it just does not feel like the
real world
at all it's no longer a part of any
conversations that i'm a part of not
because my friend group is super
homogeneous or anything like that just
because the people that i'm with this is
not what defines our our interests and
our curiosities day by day like we're
we're not uh
we're not personally motivated by it
like that and
and
so it's just like it's just lost so much
of its teeth the whole culture war thing
like you were saying about the
vaccination stuff where it's like all
right i kind of don't
care a lot about what the cdc's
recommendations are like maybe forever
it's like the bayou cried wolf isn't it
yeah if everything's racism then
nothing's racism if if everything is a
health risk then nothing's a health risk
yeah and
after a while people only get so many
chances at
singing and dancing and shouting about
stuff before you just start to switch
off and i want stuff that's going to be
useful for our like i literally have to
make the future
i literally have to put food on the
table for my kids and and my fam and i
literally have people around me who i
care
if there's things going really bad for
them like
i i want them to go better so i'm
looking for
meaningful information and insights
about where the world is going
about what what opportunity is worth
investing in so that
13 years from now you didn't just double
down on something that's totally [ __ ]
evaporated
intellectual laughing horseshit about
yeah privilege and intersectionality
there's this really cool thing i learned
about the other day called fire hosing
with with so many competing narratives
in the digital age disinformation agents
can't convince you of any single
narrative so instead they overwhelm you
with many contradictory narratives until
you start to doubt everything and become
confused demoralized and passive so this
idea that like
just like so how valuable is it for you
to be off kilter and have a walk like
it's like now i can do something with
you if you're if you if you're unsure
and insecure now i can can like direct
you in a certain way a little bit easier
it's harder to have a a sense of
place and direction
and stick with it
right that's what one of things is
valuable having a career it's like this
is the industry that i'm in and this is
you said in the car like becoming the
best podcaster you can be that's such a
direction it so has like bumpers on it
at the at the bowling alley you know you
know you know where are your god rails
that you can follow right and that is
that can be a thing that you
get to
uh i don't know that you that you that
you get to uh
you're hiring that direction
in a way that keeps you it's like a
rudder or a fin on a surfboard it keeps
you from going off and all over the
place where it's like okay you're not
being a good enough socially conscious
justice warrior you're not you don't
understand enough about the hardships
here there and other other everywhere
people use
people can supplant that with a lot of
different things though
people can decide that the thing that
they're going to pursue is going to be
the most equitable campaigning
intersectional lgbtq plus
person that they can be yeah and that's
that becomes their status game and
is it possible to say that objectively
some status games are more virtuous than
others
i don't know i'd need like a philosopher
friend here to work that one out
but i mean in terms of adding value like
real world give me tell me what is
happening maybe maybe i'm totally wrong
right maybe there is a huge problem in
the black gay and lesbian community
where they're being ostracized by the
whites in the
lesbian and gay community i'm not sure
it seems to me like time could be better
spent on
other things trying a partner to get
[ __ ]
delicious sex with
it's not that hard if you're in
especially if you're one of the g's if
you're one of the yells it's a bit more
difficult because you've got you know
you've got two gates i don't know it's
like it's just not not not where i live
it's like not where i'm from you know i
just really don't know what the weather
is about a lot of action going on with
the g's a lot of action what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace